the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
has decided to award the 2017 Nobel
Prize in Chemistry jointly to Jacques
Dabashi you're him Frank and Richard
Henderson and the Academy citation runs
for developing cryo-electron microscopy
for the high resolution structure
determination of biomolecules in
solution
fill the entwicklung decree electronic
microscopy through the whole house and
october team from biomolecules in Lu Xun
poor development electron microscopy
electronic popular determination at
resolution the last week till the
biomolecule on solution
Zara's V tau electron microscopy the
Tsukuba resolution the aplia structurae
biomolecule virus water and you see
pictures of our new Nobel laureates on
the screen above me drag the bougie was
born in 1942 in Switzerland he studied
in Barcelona in Geneva and he's
currently honorary professor at the
University of the Lausanne in
Switzerland is a Swiss citizen your Kim
Frank was born in 1940 in Germany he got
his PhD at the Technical University in
Munich mention and is currently
professor at Columbia University in New
York he is nowadays US citizen last but
not least Richard Henderson was born in
1945 in Scotland he received his PhD at
the University of Cambridge in the
United Kingdom and he is since many
years at the laboratory of molecular
biology in Cambridge and I think is the
15th Nobel laureate from that laboratory
rather impressive with that I'll give
the word to the chairman of Nobel
Committee so Roz no better please sir
she'll provide a brief summary of the
research that's been awarded today sorry
please thank you
we are made of more water than anything
else
biomolecules the molecules of life they
do their job in water so let's put them
there now they are free to move and act
and interact and do their job together
to help us execute important functions
like thinking and carrying around stuff
every protein in here is roughly ten
nanometers in diameter so if I were to
reverse this process and pull out one
million of them and put them along one
line they recovery as a centimeter cry
OEM is able to see each and every one of
these protein molecules and it can do
much better than so it can say each and
every atom inside each protein to tell
us how they are arranged to build up
their intricate structures it can do
even better than so it can show us how
the different parts of the protein moves
relative to one another when they're
executed their jobs Richard Henderson
showed the first protein structure at
atomic resolution using cryo-electron
microscopy Chuck dooba she developed a
method to take these samples of
biomolecules in water and freeze them so
rapidly that they formed a thin film in
which the water was preserved in a
liquid state
just like in glass window jørgen Frank
developed a method to combine the
information for multiple blurry images
of those individual proteins into one
sharp image soon there are no more
secrets now we can see the intricate
details of the biomolecules in every
corner of our cells
every drop of our body fluids we can
understand how they are built and how
they act and how they work together in
large communities we are facing a
revolution in biochemistry thank you
Sarah for that great introduction
now Peter can you show us perhaps what
those molecules in the glass look like
so this picture shows three examples of
structures that have been determined
using the technique that has been
developed by the laureate and the first
one on the left side is a biological
clock it's a protein complex which
controls the time in many living
organisms and this is closely related to
the price for Physiology or medicine
that we could hear about a couple of
days ago in the middle it's a pressure
sensor it's of the type that is used for
example in our ear to convert the sound
waves into electrical signals on the
right side it's a huge protein complex
that is used by Salmonella bacteria to
inject harmful substances into the host
this is the host and this is the
bathroom itself and these structures
have been determined using the
techniques developed by the laureates
which have opened up a completely new
world to us to be able to see all these
molecules inside the cell and how they
interact the challenge is that these
molecules are very small the size
relation of a molecule like the one I
showed to a human being is approximately
the same as of the human being to the
size of the moon we currently don't have
any instrument that would allow us to
see a human being on the moon from the
surface of our planet but we do have an
instrument which allows us now to see
the molecules inside our cells and not
even that we can even see the atoms that
build up this molecule
and see the details of all these
molecules the electron microscope is not
a new instrument it was developed almost
100 years ago the problem is that there
is a great challenge in studying
biological objects using electron
microscopy because there must be vacuum
inside the electron microscope and
biological objects are composed
primarily of water and if you place a
water object containing water in a
vacuum it rise and the structure changes
if you switched on the electron beam gun
the object is burned and the structure
does not even remind us about the
original object Richard Henderson
studied an organelle but an organism or
protein from an organism that lives in
salt ponds like the one shown here in
the desert this is a microorganism which
carries patches of photosynthetic
proteins on its surface and these
proteins they are arranged in regular
arrays that contain many many of these
molecules and Richard Henderson placed
these patches in the electron microscope
and by observing about 5 million of
these bacteria robson molecules at the
same time he could distribute the
electron radiation of a large number of
molecules so that each of each one of
them did not receive enough electron
radiation that would damage them but he
couldn't study the molecules and in this
way he could obtain a high-resolution
structure of the protein of bacteria
Dobson but this is a special case not
all molecules are oriented like in in
this case in this microorganism most
molecules are free or like solar showed
in water and Richard Hansen believed
that the technique could be also used to
study essentially any molecule that is
found in the cell
when we study a picture of molecules
that are in solution and this is an
example of ribosome that we see in
solution here then all the molecules are
randomly distributed in the solution so
they are difficult to find so the
challenge is now to using this very low
low electron radiation that would not
damage the molecules to actually see
them and see where they are then we have
to see how order oriented relative to
each other because we must know in order
to determine the three-dimensional
structure to to combine all these
pictures into the whole structure in
working Frank developed these methods
and it's illustrated in this schematic
illustration so here are the molecules
in solution they have different
orientation when these molecules are
illuminated by the electron beam we see
projections of these molecules like
shadows of these molecules and these
shadows differ in shape depending on the
orientation of the object that was
illuminated this can be now sorted those
that have the same shape or originate
from molecules with the same orientation
or sorted in groups and then an average
of all these pictures can be taken in
each of these groups and in this way one
can obtain sharper pictures one can
increase the signal relative to the
background noise and this is the way now
to obtain better resolution pictures
then these pictures can be combined to
build a three-dimensional structure and
this is an example of such a structure
but in order now to to obtain
information about the details about the
atoms what the water molecule looks like
inside better sample preparation methods
were needed and many people believed
that a way to prepare samples was to
free would be to freeze them the problem
is that if you place a biological object
in ice in
in in water and freeze then ice crystals
are formed around the object and the ice
crystals diffract the electron beam so
when it's illuminated all the
information is lost because the ice
crystal diffract
the electron beam but people also
believe that it would be possible
perhaps to freeze the sample fast enough
so that water would not have time to
arrange itself into crystals to form ice
but would be a structure that is is like
a liquid all the water molecules are
randomly distributed and not not forming
the ice crystals and if this is the case
then it would be possible to obtain a
short picture because all the electron
beams would be evenly absorbed by the
body
there's vitrified water at it's cold and
in this way Jacques to Bashar could
develop the technique that allowed to
see biomolecules it could contrast the
method is described in this picture so
the the sample is applied to agreed and
the the sample then in water is sponsor
the distance across this the holes in
this grid and then the sample is frozen
in a time that is cooled by liquid
nitrogen so the temperature is about my
hand - under 90 degrees it's rapidly
frozen and then the glass is formed the
water in a glass form is form is formed
across these holes this is a setup that
was built by Jacque - Borgia and we see
here it's like a catapult that is used
to to inject the sample that is here
into the cold
eita in health so it's frozen very
rapidly in order to form this vitrified
state and using this method chuck to
Bashar in the beginning of 1990 he
showed these beautiful pictures like in
this case of a virus and everyone
traveled - who are working in this field
travel to his lab in order to learn the
technique and it was then rapidly used
by many other in and many other
laboratories the technique has
transformed the
electron microscopy from technique that
could be used to just see the shapes the
outer shapes of molecules into one that
is now used to see the details the atoms
inside the molecules and the latest
technical developments occurred very
recently so it's very recent
developments that we can actually see
the details of of these molecules the
technique is also relatively rapid so
once one has samplers that can be
studied the structure can be determined
relatively rapidly and this was
exemplified it last year when the
structure of the Zika virus was
determined in just a few months and it's
in here and this structure shows the
atomic details of the surface which of
course is important when developing
drugs against the virus but the
technique is not only about seeing
molecules and I think this is fantastic
for the developments that we has already
started but we'll be seeing me also in
the future and that is because the
molecules are frozen in solution each if
a molecule does some work like the one
shown here then all these molecules are
frozen in exactly in the moment in the
different states in different structures
and it's like frames of a movie in each
each of these pictures represents a
frame and they can be put together into
a movie like the one shown here and we
can see what the molecules do so I think
in the future this is not only about
getting structures of molecules which
are in itself it's of course fantastic
but it's also for the future we'll be
able to see processes what is happening
what is going on inside the cells how do
they molecules interact how do they move
what do they do and I end this
presentation by showing the laureates
again thank you thank you Peter
for that beautiful and exciting
presentation now I hope we have
professor you are kim frank with us on
the phone dr. Frank are you there
yes hello and thanks for being with us
this is Jordan Hansen who I believe woke
you up an hour ago or so in mind now I
I'm in the session all of the Academy
and we have journalists from Sweden and
all over the world here and I'm sure
they have questions to ask you who would
like to start so much fun as usual
please Swedish television
congratulations thank you very much
we just heard some of the something
about the usefulness of your technique
technology could you in your words the
main usefulness well structure research
has been mainly domed with extol ography
for the past decades and x-ray
crystallography requires molecules to be
arranged very rigidly in or it's not
applicable to all molecules or molecules
they go through many different states
and not all these it can be captured by
x-ray ography so the entire electron
microscopy with particles Filson out of
it extends the range of molecules that
can be determined at atomic resolution
and it also makes it possible to see
these molecules in in the functional
states that are relevant or for the life
functions do you see any immediate
practical use I think that's an interest
for our journalists here well the
practical use is immense
but there's always
a long time between fundamentals of
fundamental research to make their way
into the general knowledge and and the
practice of medicine and you might know
that that are the x-ray crystallography
during the year but maybe five decades
resulted in a hundred thousand that are
all available and they now form the
fundaments of molecular medicine
medicine is no longer looking at organs
shows it looks really the processes in
the cell and this medicine has become so
powerful and the same transformation
will happen with with opposite results
that our Empire and cryo electromag
it is just not an immediate peptide
application but but several years go by
but before the practical the u.s. is
seen yeah we have a question over there
hi I'm anali mag neuron from Swedish TV
for congratulations I wonder which one
is the coolest molecule you have seen
through your microscope well for me I've
been I've been looking at drivers
Foreman's for her out of my life and for
me the coolest knowledge there's always
in the ribosome and so they reasoned
there isn't revolution that produced by
the development the very sensitive
cameras or has resulted now in in actual
images of the ribosome is there are an
incredible in
of understanding funk we can now see how
the ribosome can can distinguish between
the correct the incorrect pairing an
anticodon meaning the deep in yes
process that expects bump and now we
explained in in atomic did let me write
we have some slight problems with the
connections I'll just mentioned the
ribosome the pro the machinery that
makes proteins in the cell is the most
remarkable structure for for dr. Frank
himself and you can see it in the
details when the amino acids are put
together now so that's what's thrilling
for dr. Frank we have one more question
over there yes we were told that the
press conference that the Zika virus was
analyzed using your method could you
please elaborate a little bit about that
specific application were you involved
in that at all I I was not involved in
this
it was done by Michael Rothman at Purdue
University and actually the
reconstruction of viruses have a great
advantage over a reconstruction of
molecules without symmetry because a
single view gives you in the in this but
the case of this particular tree it
gives you a 60 used and and so you have
a more information as from a single view
methods that I developed are we're not
so important for the development of for
and for the reconstruction of the virus
but they were a start of something very
don't worry we have a question over here
thank you David Keaton from The
Associated Press a question in two parts
if I may first of all so how did you
react what was the first impression when
you received the phone call this morning
announcing this prize and the second
part is over the last few days the Nobel
Prizes that we have heard that had been
announced the sort of the importance of
the technological innovation and
breakthrough it was stressed several
times the importance of that
technological breakthrough that enabled
the scientific discoveries do you
believe that in this era today of in
scientific research that the this sort
of the technology is sort of paramount
and actually maybe the first step before
the actual fundamental science
discoveries is the first question
I I was I was fully overwhelmed I I
thought the transit of a Nobel Prize are
miniscule because there are so many so
many other innovations and and other
discoveries that happen every day
so so yeah I was I was in anyway speech
well isn't the only say this is
wonderful news and I repeated myself and
a second question um I I think I think
the the Nobel MIDI or renewable
committee's always have this pink have
this quandary of deciding whether on the
metal breakthrough it's worth surprise
or a technique technological innovation
technological innovations mind have has
much larger impact cryo-electron
microscopy supposed to completely
transform a structural biology and and
which can be seen from the fact because
solar graphics
a flock to the conferences in I am and
there are also many applications by for
stocks for postal position of students
that have been trained in extra so so so
I I do think at deciding between a
particular discovery and and a
technological breakthrough it's I would
always think that they're the impact it
are we much larger for the analogical
breakthrough okay thank you very much I
think we'll have to stop there and thank
you very much for being with us
professor Frank and we look forward to
welcoming you to Stockholm in December
thank you very much very much now are
the questions for the panel yes please
yeah thank you
I'm sufficient access all from freelance
4chan radio so far we have nine
laureates and about sevens from the USA
so I just like to ask you to have a
comment about this is it how do you
comment the research environment or
policies in the US or why it's like this
yeah thank you I'll start and maybe my
colleagues can expand the United States
has since the second after the Second
World War
allowed scientists to perform
fundamental research
to focus on important questions in
science not forcing them to immediate
applications not controlling them in a
political way and that freedom combined
with very good resources have been very
helpful for the United States but it's
not unique to the United States as I
mentioned Richard Henderson is at the
MRC the virtual molecular biology the
LMB in Cambridge UK that has fostered a
whole long list of Nobel laureates
because of the intellectual atmosphere
because of of resources for basic
research that has turned out to pay off
in practical applications later on but
they are not pushing them to try to
solve immediate practical problems but
to lay the foundation for that and I
think that has been very helpful in
other parts of the world of course they
have been less privileged situation has
been very different with that
colonialism we had Wars and so on it's
been very difficult to to mobilize
enough resources for science but it also
matters of the intellectual climate
allowed of course the academic freedom I
think is the key to making big
discoveries but what we can do as nobody
commits assists and we invite
universities and individual scientists
from all over the world to nominate
that's how we work to get in nominations
from the whole world that's an important
point we really give opportunities to
scientists in on every continent in in
most countries to nominate we make some
efforts to give that opportunity more
questions please yes it's a meaningful
from China's national Xinhua news agency
it seems to me that this year's
discovery is a combination of physics
and cameras
you know we're talking about micros
microscopy lights and imaging as well as
the molecule structures so can you tell
us how important it is for this
interdisciplinary methods in research of
chemistry in future thank you would you
like to comment on that I think it's a
very good example of how our contacts
between scientists in different
disciplines yes and I think it's the
discipline development is such that the
discipline makes more and more I think
and yes you correctly pointed out I mean
this is a particular good example were
were both technical developments and
methods mathematical tools have been
developed and also preparation
techniques so I think this works
together do these different disciplines
different backgrounds scientists work
together to develop techniques dark in
this example thank you more questions if
not then we'll close this part of the
press conference and those of you have
requested interviews you will have that
opportunity in a minute or so thank you
very much
[Music]
so thank
get up resisted this price is about
seeing the invisible can you tell us
something more about this prior year
your electron microscope I think it's
the way it's a revolution because now
it's possible to extract molecules from
the cell that are in in the same
environment as they usually in a saline
in the water and also see the structures
of these molecules but also see how they
interact with each other how how they
operate one can get since the only
particles molecules that have studied
are in solution you're frozen in a
different state and one can then combine
the different pictures to to understand
function as well dynamics and that's the
sake to understanding life
everybody knows for the microscope is
but how does this one look like it's a
big box that is I think in here 3 4 x be
taller than we are and and then there is
a chamber where one place is a sample
and then it's illuminated inside there's
vacuum inside the school and and then
there's a camera which is one of the key
components oh they say they keep
components developed most recently that
is the
use them to detect the pictures and
monitor it so it's taking like a room
it's a whole room yeah and it must be
very stable the floor must be stable
because it's sensitive to vibrations and
so so it's it's a big expensive machine
there's one in Stockholm which is shared
between Stockholm University and other
universities and it's I love love and
then there is one Union me awesome hey
yes we do use it we just started
recently because it's instrument is neo
because there we do use it in my
research also I think a lot of people
are really interested in using the
instrument because it can provide so
much information that is it's it's very
important for understanding function so
what would be your dream discovery
I think for for the future I mean first
of all it is to see the molecules we
work on I mean that's in itself it's
it's something very warm rewarding to be
able to see the objects you work on but
I think for the for the future and which
is now more and more become possible is
to observe as I mentioned before these
different states that one can freeze the
sample why a freeze the the molecules
why they do something to actually
combine the information into a movie or
they understand the dynamics how how
they interact what they do
how
what happens in inside the cell I mean
this is with purified proteins of course
but one can learn and I've tried to
understand what happens inside the cell
is really more secrets that are not
revealed in the living cell not yet
because the technique or the at the
style at the status is relatively new so
the possibilities to use this technique
to in this way way that is used today it
has only been possible since just a
couple of years so I think now it's an
explosion and a research and what is
limiting now it's it's access to the
microscope actually so it's a waiting
time it's very long I think we no new
microscopes and more microscopes
I think I'm there's a lot to be seen
there's also a very long way to develop
this one it's like since 70s or 80s I
think it's I mean from the beginning the
the problem was that studies of
biological objects in an electron
microscope it's not trivial
because there is vacuum inside which the
biological samples contain primarily
water so they dry inside and shape
changes and the pictures are useless
then the electron beam burns the
molecules which also changes the
structure even more dramatically and
this has been a challenge to to to be
able to reduce the intensity of
electrons of the radiation and yet to be
able to see something in the background
noise and this required both techniques
for
and for and developing the microscope
the technology itself but also
techniques to to be able to find the
molecules in the pictures because the
machines one has to reduce the radiation
the light in the course where equivalent
to light in a lecture
light microscope interior electrons and
then the pictures are very weak so one
has to find the what objects are one has
to see how they are related to each
other in in a space and this requires
mathematical method mathematical tools
and computer programs and this of course
the sample preparation to be able to
freeze the samples in such a way that
the picture is not distorted so all they
have been research has been going on
very actively during a long time but has
there's been a lot to do before the
technique my children to the molecules
even this very special way of freezing
the water the solution yes if I'd
water's yes yes so the idea is that in
one freeze normally when one freezes
water ice crystals are formed and ice
crystals diffract electrons so that the
information is lost because the
electrons go diffracted always so the
idea was to to freeze the water so fast
that the crystals would not have time to
form so and this is called vitrified
water or a like a glass it's the same
principle as a glass in a window it's
also a liquid all the molecules are
disordered and they are they are not
crystallized but because it's like a
liquid that is like a solid but it's
actually on windows you can see in the
lower part of all all the houses the
windows a little bit thicker and it's
the same way here yes
and so it means the same way here freeze
water sofa rapidly that that the
crystals don't have time to deform and
it's it's like a uniform glass that is
transparent or actually it does interact
with electrons but in a uniform way and
this allowed the technique to be
developed such that contrast to be
increased and anyone could see the
molecules
[Music]
in the pictures in the electron
microscope I understand so now you have
a perfect instrument modified more to do
I think I'm the new detectors which was
the latest breakthrough they are not
perfect there is still a lot to do to
improve them
also the the sample preparation methods
could be improved the way there's cryo
stage and whatever kept that the
temperature is kept constant because a
variation in the temperature can cause
movement so so there are a lot of
techniques and also I mean it's in
principle very little sample is needed
to further studies but since one has to
apply a droplet to this grid one has to
remove almost all the sample and very
very small fraction it's like a droplet
in a bathtub that is actually left so if
one could develop techniques that would
allow applying very small amounts of
samples and there is of course my many
more molecules that could be studied
because it's not possible to to purify
all molecules in an amount at an amount
that is allow studies so there are not a
lot of pieces that can be improved and I
think for the future it will
and I think that technique has locked
promise and my last question perhaps
what did the Lord say when they got the
call from Stockholm but from what we had
some problems with with a telephone line
but those that I heard were very happy
and surprised and we're looking forward
to coming to Stockholm in December
you